[Musik]
mir geht's gut ich glaube den Kameraden
geht auch ziemlich gut dementsprechend
weiter wird es jetzt gehen wir machen
jetzt die letzten Vorbereitungen so dass
wir dann in weiterer Folge in den
Übungsraum verlegen können
[Musik]
befinden
unsere Kommandanten sind vom Jahrgang
Körner und mit vor der Übung sondern die
bioas die neuen äh neue Jahrgang Nova
sowie der jetzige Jahrgang rot das ist
der erste Jahrgang wir verlegen
um 11 Uhr los starten und werden dann im
Raum fahren und das geht dann weiter
nach Regen
Videos ausgezeichnet ja trotz schlafen
[Musik]
mangelt wurde und das ist eigentlich der
schönste
[Musik]
sehr gespannt was auf mir zukommt die
nächsten zwei Wochen mir geht's gut und
wir treffen jetzt die besten
Vorbereitungen für unsere Übungen
[Musik]
und in späterer Folge wir verlegen in
unserem berührungsraum die Leute sind
angriffslustig und breite Bevölkerung
motiviert wir haben uns jetzt formiert
sind alle heiß und scharf für die
Übungen und wir verlegen jetzt dann
demnächst raus in unseren Einsatzraum